if you're a woman and you're kind of on
the lookout you really want to avoid
legit bad guys I highly recommend that
you know these traits and kind of
recognize them when you see them lack of
empathy lack of remorse they're very
comfortable lying if you catch them out
in a lie they're not embarrassed they
just keep lying some more to cover it up
they tend to have an unstable lifestyle
they move locations they move jobs a lot
they have a kind of complicated
checkered sexual history with lots of
ex-girlfriends don't want to talk about
why the breakups happen often have a
criminal record they tend to be
impulsive sensation seeking drink a lot
do a lot of drugs drive fast